Clements: Okay.
So we are now recording.
So this is gonna be recorded,
and the video will be posted
online in the next day or two.
So welcome to the Galaxy webinar
on "Connecting Galaxy
with the NIH
Sequence Read Archive, SRA."
I'm Dave Clements.
I am one of the training
and outreach people
for the Galaxy project.
Today we also have
Marius van den Beek
and Dan Blankenberg,
who are gonna join in.
In addition, we have a number
of people from the SRA itself
who are gonna chime in
as we go,
correcting us as we do things or
adding additional information.
So the slides
that we're using today,
we're not gonna spend a whole
lot of time
in slides first of all,
but the slides
do have links in them.
So that makes them useful.
The slides are at that URL
at the bottom.
So bit.ly/galaxy-sra-slides.
They're Google slides,
so...
Let's...
There we go. Okay.
So our agenda
is short and sweet.
We're going
to introduce SRA,
we're gonna introduce Galaxy
and then we're gonna talk
about SRA and Galaxy,
and we're gonna do that
by a live demo.
Please ask questions as we go.
So there's a Q&A window
in Zoom.
There should be a Q&A icon
at the bottom
of your Zoom window.
Click on that
to type your question.
Everyone can see your question.
Whoever is not speaking
will try and collate those
and then throw them
at the current speaker.
So if your question
doesn't get asked immediately,
please be patient
and it will be asked,
time allowing.
And we want to
cover questions as we go.
We can also cover questions
at the end.
But we're all big fans
of questions as we go.
So, okay.
So when you registered,
we asked, "Is there anything
you would like to specifically
learn about in this webinar?"
We got a whole range of options,
some of which we're gonna
cover today
and some of which we're not.
So we are gonna talk
about SRA and Galaxy,
and we're gonna focus on
the parts of SRA and Galaxy
that have to do
with that interaction.
So everything
in the "Today" column,
we should be covering.
Things in the "Not Today"
covering --
Sorry, things in the "Not Today"
column we could cover,
but not today.
We don't have time.
So we can do all these things in
SRA or in Galaxy,
but we're not going
to discuss those today.
We will give you some pointers
on how to get more information
about things like that.
And lastly, we had one person,
God bless you, whoever you are,
who said, "The meaning of life."
And I do like to think you could
find that in SRA Galaxy,
and maybe we will.
Maybe we won't, but we'll try.
So that's what
we're gonna cover.
So let's talk about SRA,
Sequence Read Archive.
So the first thing,
I'm gonna try and do a poll.
Poll.
Can I do a poll here?
It's only giving me one poll.
I don't want that poll.
Crap.
Okay.
So my first poll
has gone awry already.
Okay.
Uh...
Let's...
Well, we're just not
gonna poll you guys.
Sorry.
Okay.
So what I was gonna do
is ask how many people
have experience with SRA
and how deep is that experience?
I'm going to assume
that you have a little bit
of experience with SRA.
I'm gonna do the walk-through
in the SRA part
and Marius is gonna do
the walk-through
in the Galaxy part.
I had another poll,
or so I thought,
to ask about Galaxy
and your experience with that.
So but we're just gonna plow
ahead under the assumption
that you have used SRA,
but you may or may not
be an expert.
So what is SRA?
It's part of NCBI,
which is part of NIH,
and it's the primary archive
of unassembled reads.
So it doesn't have
final assemblies.
It doesn't have
reference sequence.
What it has is reads.
So things that come off
the instruments.
And that distinction
is worth keeping in mind.
This is where you go when you
want access to the source data
for reference read --
Yeah, for reference sequence,
okay?
Things that are in GenBank.
This is where you find
the evidence behind it.
So it's a great place to get,
you know, I just said that.
Okay, so another point,
all of SRA,
every bit of it is now
on Amazon Web Services
and Google Compute.
So it's all in the cloud.
This means you can have
fast access to it.
It's a very powerful feature
and it's relatively recent.
One note -- you will also hear
referred to
as the Short Read Archive.
Its former name.
It hasn't been
the Short Read Archive
for a long time,
but I'm older than that.
So occasionally,
I'll call it Short Read Archive
and I apologize for that.
It is not just for short reads.
It has all kinds of reads
on it.
Okay.
So and SRA, folks,
again, please feel free
to chime in and say,
"Well, actually, Dave..."
And we'll see.
Oops. Wrong window. Okay.
So today we're gonna spend
our time in SRA
in two things --
one is Entrez
and one is the SRA Run Selector.
Entrez is a query interface
that's used across a lot
of NCBI resources.
So you may already
be familiar with it,
even if you don't think you are.
And the SRA Run Selector
is a newer method
of interacting with SRA data.
We're gonna use both.
They complement each other.
They don't replace each other.
So...
Okay.
And I'm gonna throw this slide
at one of the SRA folks.
Or maybe I won't.
Skripchenko: So I will --
My name is Yuriy Skripchenko,
and I wanted
to let everybody know
that SRA is going through
some changes,
and we would really love
to have community feedback
on those changes that we
are thinking about doing.
And so we have this request
for information open.
So please go to the link
on the slide
and provide us your feedback
on our plans
for the changes
that we're thinking of doing.
I think it's very important
to get the community's feedback,
to make sure that the things
we're doing matches
your expectations
and in the long term
will help you perform science
faster and better and provides
kind of more research
opportunities for everybody.
Thank you.
Clements: If you're part
of the Galaxy community,
that link is also available
in the June newsletter
and we've tweeted it
a couple of times
on our Twitter feed.
We've actually retweeted it
from NCBI.
So you can find that
on Twitter as well.
So let's talk about Galaxy.
Again, rough introduction before
we dive in
to the actual hands-on part.
Galaxy is a data integration
and analysis platform.
And it's funded for and
developed for life scientists.
It's actually used
in all sorts of things.
But that's our goal,
is to be for life science.
We are, in addition
to being that platform,
we're a worldwide community
and we really can't stress
that enough.
The community is what makes
Galaxy what it is.
And it's not just the coders,
the developers.
It's the users,
people who do training,
people who provide
infrastructure.
It's a huge, very vibrant
community and without it,
Galaxy would probably not
be around anymore.
So...Yeah.
So I like to stress
both those things.
They're equally important --
the platform and the people.
Galaxy's available in a whole
bunch of different ways.
There are over 100 free,
online web servers out there.
Something like 140, 130,
the last I knew.
If you follow that first URL,
at the bottom,
you'll go to
the platform directory.
It's also available on
commercial and academic clouds
so you can easily
watch it on Amazon
or if you're in the U.S.,
you can easily watch it
on jet stream.
People have published it
in containers
and virtual machines
so you can launch it
on your laptop very easily.
It's also open source software
that can be installed anywhere.
And that is the most common
use case for Galaxy.
It's installed all over
the world at research
institutions, universities,
usually behind firewalls.
But that is our most
popular deployment.
So...Okay.
We also have
a lot of training materials
and we run a tutorial
to highlight how to use SRA.
We'll use that later today.
But there is a huge library.
Again, this is part
of a community effort.
This is entirely run by the
community
to publish tutorials
on how to use Galaxy
for different domains
and all sorts of topics there --
epigenetics, genome annotation.
We also
have tutorials on Galaxy basics
like data manipulation,
user interface.
In addition, we have tutorials
on how to write tutorials,
which was very useful
for the three of us
in the last few days.
And we also have tutorials
on how to run a Galaxy server.
So it's a very robust library
of training methods
and something like 160 people
have contributed so far to that.
So today, we're gonna do
a live demo.
We're gonna use
a COVID-19 example.
But that domain
doesn't actually matter.
What we're demonstrating today
is how to use SRA
and doesn't have to be viral
reads you're gathering from SRA,
it can be anything.
It can back RNA-seq experiments,
it can back ChIP-seq
experiments.
You name it.
If it's in SRA,
we can get it into Galaxy
with what we're going
to show you today.
So and the rough plan
is we're gonna go from
Galaxy to SRA to Galaxy
to get metadata
and then we're
gonna go back to SRA.
Well, we're gonna run a tool
that goes back to SRA
to grab the actual data itself.
And then we're going
to run a short, sweet analysis
in Galaxy that uses
the SRA data.
Now, the second link
at the bottom there
may or may not work yet.
I don't know --
-It works.
Clements: It works. Yes.
Okay. So reverse that.
It works. It's brilliant
because we're on the ball.
Okay.
So the second link
will take you to that tutorial.
And I'm not gonna go step
through step in that tutorial,
But that's basically the process
that me and Marius
are doing today
is what's in that tutorial.
Okay?
So a couple of caveats
before we do this.
So SRA is this wonderful
resource chock-full of data.
And it's growing rapidly,
as you may know,
but submitters don't often
provide complete
or correct metadata.
And we may see that in some
of our exploration today.
There's a discrepancy
between SRR and ERR entries.
Does anybody want to expand
on what that is?
Van den Beek: Yes.
So actually, I don't know,
maybe Yuriy can correct me,
but some thing --
Well, there are several places
where primary data
is deposited.
So there is a shorter archive
here at NCBI.
There is also Short Read Archive
in European under EMBL umbrella.
European Nucleotide Archive.
And so sometimes, especially
for COVID, for SARS-CoV-2 data,
because it's it's released
essentially on a daily basis,
They're not always in sync.
So, for example,
if you're trying
to pull ERR European extensions
from SRA from here,
sometimes that does not work.
So there is
some discrepancy here
and also in some cases
when you are trying to download
really large sets
of reads, thousands of reads,
then some of them
may statistically fail
for a variety of reasons.
Most often for network
connectivity reasons.
Clements: So the tool
we're going to use today
is actually built
to deal with that.
We won't -- I'm pretty sure
we won't see that today
because we're doing very small
data sets on a small number.
But the tool is actually
built to be rerun
and just get the things
that fit, so...
Okay. I think --
Yeah. Okay.
So let's go back here.
I'm gonna get out of this.
Escape.
And let's go
to the Galaxy training.
I go there, what happens?
Okay.
Let me know if my screen share
is no longer behaving.
Is it still behaving?
Yes. Okay. Good. Okay.
I'm gonna zoom in just a tad.
Let's do one more plus.
Okay.
So this is the tutorial.
It's -- Yeah, so I used a
SARS-Co--
Yeah, it uses COVID
as an example,
but again,
doesn't actually matter
for what we're
talking about today.
So I'm gonna scroll down.
It's a typical tutorial,
some leading questions,
some objectives.
What are requirements?
All sorts of things.
And the aim and the agenda.
You'll see as we go through,
there's lots of text,
there's comments, there's tips.
There's also these hands-on.
So if you're already familiar
with SRA and Galaxy
and you know what you're doing,
you just want to learn
how to do it,
you want to focus on
just the hands-on parts
of these tutorials, okay?
If you're learning either
or both of those,
it might pay to
actually read the tutorial,
in which case, it will
take you longer,
but hopefully it contains
some useful insight.
Okay.
So what we're gonna do again
is we're gonna go
to usegalaxy.org.
And from there,
we're gonna go to SRA.
We're gonna explore SRA
for a while.
And then we're gonna
send data back to Galaxy.
So let's do that,
and we're gonna start out
in Entrez.
So let's do this.
Okay.
So this is gonna land us
on usegalaxy.org,
which is --
I'm gonna zoom in
just a tad.
Okay.
Which is the Galaxy server
run by the projects in the U.S.
So, again, anybody can set up
their own Galaxy server.
There are over 100 public ones.
This is the one
for the Galaxy --
that the Galaxy team
in the U.S. runs.
It might be the largest one
in the world, I think.
So it's a three-panel
interface over here.
You have your Tools
in the middle.
Once we get going,
you'll see Datasets and Tools.
So we run our Tools
from the middle.
And we also preview
and view our Datasets here.
Third panel is the History.
So this is what we've done.
And so far it says, "Hey, Dave,
your history is empty."
And it says, "You can
do stuff," so cool.
I will do stuff.
Okay.
And in fact, what I'm gonna do
is get data
from an external source.
And so the very first thing I do
is I come over here
and it's like, "Okay,
what do I want to do?
I want to get data from SRA."
So I click on that.
And get data,
download and extract. Okay.
This stuff looks great because
this is what I want to do.
But if I click on --
Well, eventually I'll click
on that,
but right now what I want to do
is go to the SRA server
because I don't yet know
the details of what I want.
I actually want to go to SRA
and figure out exactly
what I want.
So I'm gonna click on that.
SRA server.
And now it transferred me.
I'm gonna zoom in.
Galaxy into SRA.
Now, for right now,
this feature is available
on usegalaxy.org.
Support for this feature
is in the 20.05 release,
which has not yet come out.
But the release of that
is imminent.
And once it's in
the 20.05 release,
we'll see it
start to filter out
to other Galaxy
servers as well.
But right now,
it's only in usegalaxy.org.
And so what's happening behind
the scenes is when I said,
"Hey, go to the SRA server,"
it's goes from Galaxy to SRA
and it tells it
which server it came from.
And SRA is going
to remember that.
And in the end,
when I ship stuff back,
it remembers what server --
Now, again, as of right now,
there's only one server,
but eventually you'll be able to
call this from any server
that supports SRA.
So we're in SRA and this
is the Entrez interface,
which may look familiar
if you've used NCBI
or SRA before
and you can type anything here.
And so I'm gonna borrow
something from Yuriy
because Yuriy likes dolphins.
So we're gonna search
for dolphin, okay?
And it comes back
and it gives us 720 results.
And we go down
and there's a lot of them.
And that's cool. Okay.
So I know, "Great.
It's kind of working."
And then I get kind of curious
and I go, "Okay,
well, I used to work
on a kidney project,
so I like to search
for dolphin kidneys."
And note that
it looks different now, okay?
There's only one match
for dolphin kidney.
And it's this one.
So it didn't display it
as a list.
It just took me
directly to it.
And it might be pretty old
because it's 454.
Well, that's cool. Okay.
So I've got dolphins,
I got dolphin kidneys.
If I type kidney...
I go back
and there we go.
Now I've got 124,000 entries.
So a lot more than
I did for dolphin, okay.
Dolphin -- If I could spell.
So if I go back to dol...
dolphin.
I have a mechanical keyboard,
which is why
you can hear me type.
I get 720. Okay.
Now there's a bunch of things
we could --
Yeah, I typed dolphin,
I typed kidney.
I could also go into the
advanced query form right here.
This is a query builder.
So if you're familiar
with Entrez,
it has a very sophisticated
and powerful syntax
for specifying
exactly what you want
and you can specify it
in very particular fields.
So author --
I only want to see entries
from this author,
maybe from this bio sample,
bio projects.
Maybe I'm only interested
in homosapiens.
I only want to see things
that are recent
or that are old, who knows.
There's a bunch of things
you can put in here.
And you can build this
incredibly complex query
and then it will put it
into Entrez's syntax,
which is difficult to remember.
But you can use this form
to create it.
So we could today
use this advanced form
to create our query, okay?
Now, we're not going to.
What we're gonna do instead
is we're gonna search
for SARS --
See if I can remember this --
CoV-2.
Okay?
And that's what we actually
want to run today -- SARS-CoV-2.
And we note we have
25,000 entries, okay?
We're on page 1
of 1,200 pages.
So that's kind of a lot of data.
Okay.
And now we could narrow things
down here further.
We could say,
"Okay, I want to see stuff
from Egypt or from Thailand
or from wherever."
I could do that here.
I'm not going to because
what I want to do
is switch --
Run Selector interface.
So the Run Selector
complements Entrez,
as I mentioned earlier,
but it's a lot friendlier.
So we're going
to switch to that.
I'm gonna send
all 25,000 of these,
which is way too many
to use in a tutorial,
probably way too many to use
in any meaningful experiment
that we're gonna run,
but maybe.
So I'm gonna click on
"Send results
to Run Selector" right there.
And this is gonna take me
to a different interface.
All 25,000.
Okay. Here we are.
There's our runs --
Oh. So something to note.
When we were in S--
Sorry, so back in Entrez,
we had a number of entries
and it wasn't this number.
It was a different number.
And the reason that number
is different is because
in Entrez, we're looking at
SRA experiments.
An experiment is a package
that wraps a bunch
of things, including runs.
Now, we're interested in runs
because that's where
the sequence data is.
So this number is different.
It's usually gonna be larger
because experiments
typically have --
Well, they don't
They can have one or more runs.
Okay?
And here,
it's a little bit larger.
So don't expect this number
to be the same
because we've now gone
from experiments to runs.
It's the same data. We're just
seeing it in more detail.
So that's what this is.
And it says, "Hey, we got a lot
of stuff here.
We got a tera--
1.8 terabytes,
3.9 terabases."
Something to note is we have
this tantalizing
Galaxy button here,
but it's not currently active.
So our goal is to make
that active.
Now, in Entrez,
we could type in surgeons,
which, again, very sophisticated
and narrow in on things.
With Run Selector,
it provides a faceted search
interface,
which is over here
in the filters list.
So that's what this is.
And these items
correspond to columns.
Now, if we scan this,
we have a lot of metadata
about all of our 25,000 runs.
It goes over and over and over.
That's a huge amount of stuff.
Okay?
And a lot of these columns
are reflected here.
And they show up
in the filters list
if they are suitable
for faceted search,
which is what we're using.
Columns that are suitable
for faceted search
are two types of columns.
One is it has a limited
number of discrete values.
Okay? So let's see.
Assay type. Let's click on that
for instance.
So I just clicked on assay type.
And it shows me down here.
Okay, I've got one, two, three,
four, five, six, seven,
eight different values
for assay type.
Now, if assay type had
3,000 values,
it wouldn't show up in this list
because the Run Selector
can't build
a meaningful interface
from 3,000 values, okay,
but it has a limited number.
There's a default you can
control with this cog, okay,
that says,
"Well, I want more than 10.
I want 15 or 20."
I don't think you can say
3,000.
But this allows us to say,
"I only want
to see things that are active."
Okay?
And you can click on that.
And now it's going
to narrow this list.
We went from 24,960
down to 21,000.
Maybe I want to throw
in RNA-seq as well.
And now that number
goes up again.
And then I decide, "Actually,
they want to drop the files."
And now I'm down to 1,800 items
again.
Okay. I can also do what's --
Let's see.
I don't know.
I don't know what's
in cell type. Let's take a look.
So I clicked on cell type
and now we come down here.
And I've got tracheal.
I've got empty.
And maybe I'm
particularly interest--
Yeah. I'm particularly
interested
in lung adenocarcinoma.
Hopefully I pronounce
that correctly.
So I click on that.
And so now I've got
the intersection of RNA-seq
and lung adenocarcinoma.
And I've got 56 items,
which are both of those.
Okay?
Now, before I click that...
A lot of numbers here.
These are subsets
within this set.
So if I unclick that...
These numbers, do they change?
Oh, they don't change.
Okay.
I take that all back.
Okay?
Okay, so you can play with this
and you can make
your queries
as sophisticated as you want.
Now, this is built
as a query interface,
but it's also a great interface
for understanding the data.
So we've got 25,000 rows here.
You don't want to spend hours
going through
assay type columns
or paging through this
to see what
the different options are.
You just want to type on
assay type
and say, "What's in here?"
Okay.
So assay type is kind of,
you know, it's kind of
an easily understood thing
even for me and non-biologists.
But there are also things like
isolation source
post-associated.
I don't know what that means,
but I come here
and I can maybe figure it out.
Maybe I have enough background
to figure out what this means.
Isolation source
post-associated.
So there could be columns here
where it's not exactly clear
what's going on.
And you can use the Run Selector
to export your data.
Okay.
So...
it's a much friendlier
interface.
Okay. Now, today,
since we're running a workshop,
we're not gonna do
any of that.
What we're gonna do is get
a very small sample.
Okay?
And let's see.
Let's skip ahead right there.
Okay, we're gonna do
a very small sample,
and we're gonna just cut
and paste this
into the found item search box.
Okay?
Now, in reality, this is not
what you're gonna do
with the Run Selector.
The Run Selector exists so you
can do sophisticated queries.
But we're doing
a workshop today.
And yeah,
it's just not gonna happen.
We need these four items.
Now, these are preselected.
Let's see.
Marius is gonna explain them,
but --
Oops, sorry. Wrong one.
These are preselected to get us
some geographic variation.
So let's --
let's go back here.
And I could paste this,
you know, the same string
into Entrez.
And I would get
the same results.
But from Entrez,
I can't ship things to Galaxy.
I have to go
to the Run Selector first.
Oops. Where'd it go?
I have to clear out that search.
Yes. Okay.
So now we've got these four,
and these four
were hand-picked again
for the, you know,
let's see, for the tutorial.
So, again, you wouldn't
do this in reality.
Note that Galaxy
is still not highlighted.
So how are we gonna get
Galaxy highlighted?
In this case, I want
all of these,
so I'm gonna click on that.
If I only wanted a few of these,
I would click individually,
boom, boom, but I want all.
Okay? No questions yet.
Good.
Well, that's not good.
But no questions.
Okay.
So note, until we do that,
that's not highlighted.
As soon as I highlight
any of these,
I can ship it to Galaxy.
So that's what I'm gonna do.
SRA, folks, is there anything
that should be highlighted
before we bounce out of SRA,
the Run Selector?
Skripchenko:
No, I think you're good,
but you might want to select
those four individually.
Clements: Oh. Sorry. Okay.
So why is that, Yuriy?
Skripchenko:
Oh, just looks like
you have
the entire data set selected
and not just the four.
So when you look at under
selected tab,
it looks like it says
24,000 is selected.
Clements: Wow. Okay.
One, two, three, four.
Thank you.
Okay. See,
I didn't know that, Yuriy.
I could have had a disaster
here
where we spent
the rest of our lives
waiting for 24,000 items to go.
Thank you, Yuriy.
Okay.
Van den Beek:
It's just metadata.
It wouldn't
have been a catastrophe.
Clements: That's true.
Yes, Marius' point is
we wouldn't actually send
1.8 terabytes.
We would actually send,
let's see, metadata
for 1.8 terabytes.
Okay. Thank you, Yuriy,
for saving our day.
Okay.
So with that,
we're gonna head back to Galaxy.
So let's click on that.
We head back to Galaxy
and a couple of things --
We get that big, green box
and it goes away.
Okay, if you're not familiar
with Galaxy,
that big, green box is
necessary,
but it's not sufficient.
And what it means
is that we have a handshake
between SRA and Galaxy.
And if you get data from UCSC
or anywhere else,
that's what that big,
green box means.
It means we had a handshake,
and the handshake went okay.
It does not mean
we have your data yet.
And so, as we can see here,
we're in Galaxy.
We have an unnamed history.
It no longer says,
"Dave, you got nothing."
It says, "Oh, there's this thing
called SRA."
Now, that little icon,
that clock icon says,
"Hey, your request has cued.
It hasn't started yet."
Right now,
it's transferring the data.
So we're actively talking back
and forth
between Galaxy and SRA.
Data is coming over.
And now we actually
have the data in Galaxy.
Van den Beek:
Should I take over here?
Clements: Yes, you should.
Thank you.
Van den Beek:
I'll share your screen.
Clements:
Yeah. Details, man.
Okay.
I'm gonna stop sharing it
if I can figure it out.
Okay.
I have stopped sharing.
Marius.
And, people,
please ask questions.
We don't have any yet.
Van den Beek: Okay,
so I've done the same today
that Dave just did.
I have selected for you
three data sets,
and that's what
we have in the current version.
[ Speaks indistinctly ]
So. Okay.
So this is the metadata
that we got from yesterday.
And you see here a small
preview.
We can scroll up.
Of course,
you click on the icon.
The data set will load
and you see here that we have
this first line, the header.
And then we have the most
important thing
that we're interested in
is the Rom sessions,
so this first column.
And we have all the metadata
that we already saw
in the Run Selector.
So this is now within Galaxy,
and we can see these data sets
from three different countries.
And that is why
I have picked them.
So this is not yet the entire
data set as it is on the SRA.
This is just a little.
So the next step
is we need to download the data
and to do that, we will use
the download, right?
[ Speaks indistinctly ]
So, yeah,
we have to download.
Now, with this metadata file,
you can download
the actual data set.
So what we want
to use and, again,
you can follow the tutorial.
You want to use this tool.
So as Dave said,
this is the tool...panel.
So here are your tools.
And they are grouped
within sections.
But you can also search.
So this was called [inaudible]
Download.
Perfect.
Okay.
And there are multiple options
how we can download
the data set,
so if you already
have the extension,
you just need to download
the single extension.
You can type it in like
this one here.
And I downloaded it.
That is also useful
if you know the extensions,
because, for instance,
we'll be doing
the analysis paper right here.
We want to focus on the data
we can select.
So for that, you click here
on this thing
that says, "Select info type."
And we select list
of SRA sessions.
Since this is the only data set,
we have no history.
It is automatically selected.
But if it was not,
you would here --
you would be able to click here
and choose the data set
that you would like.
So we can do that.
So what happened here?
This is the history.
In the history, data sets appear
as they have been generated.
So gray means
that the data sets,
you can actually
send them off
to the computing facilities,
but, um...
That's fine.
And as soon as they are
running, they will be orange.
And then they will turn green.
Alright.
So we said this here.
Okay, so we're going to do
varied analysis,
and someone can help me
if we have a reference.
So we'll be able to download
the reference data.
So typically,
you would fetch reference data
from the NCBI resources.
They hold the reference genome.
But for this tutorial,
we've also automated
the reference sequence
which is archived
or scientific data.
So you can get the word out
from the tutorial.
Okay, so...
We have received this data set
through the SRA server itself,
but if you want to upload
any other data set,
this is the main way
to upload data.
So this opens this model
and there are multiple ways
to add data sets.
We can upload files
or if it's simple data,
you can just paste them.
So in our case,
we can paste it here.
We can give it a name.
We don't need to name it.
[ Speaks indistinctly ]
Now we can start.
And as with the SRA data set
that we're currently
downloading here,
we're also a reference.
So the download has finished.
It is a long file,
so we found three
data sets,
which makes sense
because the data sets
that we have selected
are prepared
and data sets that were
generated in a sequence.
[ Speaks indistinctly ]
And if we are looking
at the output of the SRA
download tool,
you'll see that these are
in here.
So I could say one more thing.
This is a normal data set.
This is a collection.
And so collections
are collections of data sets
grouped together.
So we can see here,
we have these
three different sections.
And we can go down
into this collection
and we can go deeper
and see that we have
forward and reverse.
[ Speaks indistinctly ]
We can also take a quick look.
This is a compressed file,
but Galaxy knows how to display
compressed files.
[ Speaks indistinctly ]
Your sequence,
your header lines,
and the encoded qualities.
Okay.
So now we have the data sets
and we have the reference genome
so we can continue our analysis.
One thing that is important
to do in some type of analysis
and in general is to change
sequencing the vectors.
These contain
biological information,
so we need to get rid of them.
For this, we can use a tool.
We have many different tools.
And again,
there are tutorials on this.
In this case, we would use what
is called Speed.
And we have paired that data,
so we would select "paired."
And we have it
under collection,
so you could say
"paired collection."
And there is only one
paired collection.
So it has been preselected,
but otherwise, there would be
multiple data sets here.
Clements: Marius.
We have a question
from Pablo Cataldo.
"Should we download and process
data from single
and paired ends separately
in Galaxy?"
Van den Beek:
So it is not necessary.
If this was a mix of single
and paired data sets,
you would get the paired
data set here
and single data sets there.
In practical terms,
we often separate them
so that we can run
a series of analysis.
We can run workflows,
which are a series of analysis.
And then we first
pick the paired data sets
and then the single data sets,
because they may need
different parameters.
But in principle, there is --
You can download
and single and paired.
And it doesn't have
to be [inaudible]
It can be anything
that the SRA has.
[ Speaks indistinctly ]
All data sets.
Clements: Thanks very much.
Van den Beek: It's a good
question. Thank you.
Okay. So...
[ Speaks indistinctly ]
Now, I didn't follow
the tutorial,
but that's not good.
In fact, what we should
have done is run by Speed.
The connection.
And then we would like
to output the Json report.
After we're done
with the analysis,
we will use this,
so we would get a report,
which is beautiful.
And we get a Json report,
which is machine readable
which we will use to generate
the bigger report.
Blankenberg: Need to select
the correct
input data set as well.
Select the fastp output.
Van den Beek:
Not a problem.
Galaxy is very patient.
It's very good
for dummies like me.
And the approach here
is that once you know
what you are doing,
you can generate a workflow
to want to think about this,
do what you want to do.
Alright. So the first --
So the first run
has completed,
but we're missing
the Json report.
Well, we can already
take a look at this.
So we see that there is
a quick overview
of what is has done.
There are some statistics.
So most of the bases
are really good.
So here's the quality
and the more
high-quality bases we have,
the better.
And again, there are
more extensive tutorials
on how to interpret
this kind of data.
Alright.
So after that, we can align
the sequencing leads
back to the genome
to see where they align.
And this is the basis
for the actual learning.
So for the alignment, we will
use a tool called EW.
And so here we need to select
a reference genome.
And for most organisms,
we are ready for typical
organisms.
We provide indexes of genomes
that you can use.
But in our case,
we're using SARS-CoV-2.
And maybe you're working
with that reference, too.
So...
So we're not a model organism.
So you can also select
to build a custom index
and we're going to do that.
So here you will say that we are
going to select [inaudible]
[ Speaks indistinctly ]
We already had one.
So this is preselected.
We have a paired collection.
And we want to use fastp.
And here we have multiple data,
but we want to run
the last few months here.
And that is all
we need to do here.
We have much more --
many more options.
So, again, execute typically
has all the options
that are available
on the command line,
but also try to keep it simple.
So we have some presets.
Actually, EW also has
the same presets.
So that's great.
We can run.
That's going now.
And another thing to point out
and skip ahead here
is that notice that
we ran down the three extensions
and they're doing this
for each of the three data sets
because this is a collection.
The jobs run for...
And every two execution runs
for each
individual item in collection.
So if you ever think,
"Wow, this is too much clicking
in Galaxy,"
put things in a collection
and everything will be done
for each and every collection.
And it also automatically
keeps the name.
So we can see for instance here.
This is no extension
we had previously
so there's no way
we can make sets.
Another thing
that is great about Galaxy
is you don't need to wait until
the job is run
and finished in green
to continue.
So I can demonstrate this.
So the next step
is removing duplicate leads.
You see duplicates
or hope to get duplicates.
For this, we will use
marked duplicates
from the sweep.
Clements: So while that runs,
there have
been several questions
in the Q&A that aren't
either directly relevant
to what Marius was just talking
about at the time
or about something
we've talked about earlier.
We're answering those questions
in Q&A via text.
So be sure to check that out.
Sorry, Marius.
Van den Beek:
Okay, thank you, Dave.
Again,
keep the questions coming.
Questions are good.
Alright.
So one thing,
I also skipped ahead.
You have multiple ways
to use data sets.
If you have
a single data set,
like the initial data set,
this data set
that is just one single entity,
this is how we would run
on a single entity.
You can run a multiple series
or you can run one collection.
So whenever I'm running
these things in parallel,
I'm using this.
And you see,
it's already preselected here.
And we don't need to wait
for the data set to finish.
We can already execute
while it is already running.
I am too slow
to actually get there.
So this is faster
and can explain,
which is a good thing.
So we only set in here
that we need to change
from the default
is we want to remove
the duplicates for anyone.
So typically we would keep
the duplicates,
but having the installer
take care of
not overestimating
the amount of leads.
But here, we will say yes.
And keep going.
Alright, after this,
we can generate some basic
statistics about the alignment.
And for this,
we're going to use these stats.
And note that I am
usually not using the sections
as they are here,
because Galaxy has many,
many, many tools.
And you can find them
by topic by section.
But if you're following
the story,
it's much easier to just search.
Okay, so this time it seems
that I still have some time
to actually run a tool,
so we will select
the duplicate output.
[ Speaks indistinctly ]
Reference points, regions.
Alright.
Okay, so the next step
is the leads.
So often in...
When you have insertions
or deletions,
there are sometimes equally
good options
for the designer to place
and to have a common
set of coordinates.
There is alignments
that one can do.
This is especially important
when calling
for insertions and deletions.
So with this,
we would use an old trick.
And because it's blank,
this realignment,
we need a reference genome.
And as I said,
if we didn't prepare
a reference to it already,
you can always select history
as the source.
This is our reference genome.
[ Speaks indistinctly ]
And then we need
to do an additional step
before we can go on,
which is answer
in the qualities.
So to do that, we...
[ Speaks indistinctly ]
So, again, we have
a simple data suppression.
Maybe I can just show that
when you only want
to take a single data set
out of the collection,
you can actually go
into the collection here
and then choose
individual data sets.
We want to get a formal
process on the data,
so we're not going to do this.
These are the options
that are created
for this addition,
the qualities.
And with that,
we can finally do the actual
variant quality,
which we'll do for variance.
So you see that it has
multiple steps,
the speed steps
and the preparation
of data sets.
You can find more information
on the COVID-19 portal.
[ Speaks indistinctly ]
Okay.
So, as I mentioned,
so you always need to select
your correct data set here
and it will select
and use appropriate data sets.
In our case,
this is the case filings.
Correct.
Now, we need to set
the correct options again
to provide reference
to the history.
We're going to be able
to call the variance
across the entire reference.
But there is an option
to specify
just some subset of the regions.
We're going to call assemblies
and insertions deletions.
We're going to set
some additional options.
We're going to say that we want
as the minimum coverage 50,
so meaning sites that have less
than 50 leads
will not be uncovered.
[ Speaks indistinctly ]
So this setting is important
to make sure
that you're not calling
ambiguous alignments.
And...
We are going to say...
[ Speaks indistinctly ]
So, again, these are settings
that need
some additional explaining,
but that's outside of the scope
of the tutorial for today.
Alright.
So this is the action.
The next step
after the variant quality.
So the variant quality
offers a BCF file,
which is a standard format
for describing variants
and you can visualize
them in a genome browser.
So that actually has
integrations for IGB,
for Trexster,
for JBrowse, and others.
And it's also very easy.
[ Speaks indistinctly ]
Okay. So the next step is
that we will run [inaudible]
which is a tool that
looks at the variant
and predicts what, in fact,
the variant actually has.
Okay. And there are tools
with variants.
So there is a special version
just for SARS-CoV-2,
which takes care of the multiple
overlapping living things
that are inside the genome.
So we're gonna use this one.
As import, we need to select
the BCF file we just generated.
It is BCF format.
The genome is already correct.
We want to create
a BCF again.
We also...Sorry.
Is that correct?
Let me just check.
Yes, BCF is correct.
It would also create
a [inaudible]
which you can use to generate
a summary report.
It will not have any upstream
and downstream intervals.
This is an option
that is more appropriate
when you're looking at,
you know, variants
from non-binary sequences.
Um...options.
Okay.
The other options.
We don't care
about these things.
Okay.
So that describes the effect
that the mutation has.
And we can -- we can we can open
a BCF file now
just to give you an idea
how this looks
in case you've not
seen this before.
So you had your chromosome.
You have a position.
You have some optional things
that you can give variants,
but we're not doing this.
And then you have
the reference base
and you have the ultimate base.
You have a quality column.
We can apply filters
in case --
We did apply some filters.
You have here either
pass or fail.
This is an option.
[ Speaks indistinctly ]
And then you have
various information.
[ Speaks indistinctly ]
So what fraction of ultimate
bases are supported by leads,
from proper leads?
And then you have the type
of variant and solution,
but this doesn't really
tell me yet
what is the effect
that it has.
Is it a synonymous variant?
So for this, it is still a "F."
So you can see right here,
it does have this information
in this column here,
but again,
that is not super easy to read.
So now we can use this,
which generates a table
with just the information
that we need.
We can select the...
Here there are some additional
things that are interesting.
[ Speaks indistinctly ]
So this is the last step
that generates data.
Now we are going to summarize.
[ Speaks indistinctly ]
It's a very great tool
for generating
those kind of reports.
So we have results from past
two, which was --
Okay. So even copy/pasting
is not always foolproof.
And before --
But another thing --
You know, when things go wrong,
you want to understand
what is going on.
So this is very nice.
I can actually show you
that if I don't know
what is going on here,
I could hit this button here
to submit a bug report
and somebody from our team
will respond.
And that's, you know,
"What went wrong?"
So you could say, "Hello.
I tried to get assist,
but I don't know
what I did wrong."
So we receive this report
and look at this.
We try to help you
however we can.
It also already says here
that there was an exception.
So you see here.
[ Speaks indistinctly ]
So we actually want to help.
And in fact,
we can use the rewind button.
This is a very cool feature
in Galaxy.
And so that this was
all part of a database
for disability reasons.
So if something goes wrong
or you want
to change a parameter,
you can hit this
rewind button.
And so all we need to do here
is change H1 for Chrome.
And then we can run again.
[ Speaks indistinctly ]
Alright.
So back to what you said.
So we have a fastq report.
And there is only one data
set that is compatible,
so it's very easy
to select this.
We also have a report
and some stats.
So this is this data set here.
And...we have...
snip and report.
[ Speaks indistinctly ]
Okay. So now,
what did you see this morning?
We can have a look
at these tables,
so this is considerably
more friendly than it was.
So this is a regular table
that you could download
and put in a spreadsheet,
editorial,
or you can have a look here.
So...
See here which data set this is,
and I'm always hoping
just the first one,
you can see that there is
a varying number of...
number of lines in the data set,
and this corresponds
to the number of variants
that it found,
you see here the impact, so...
For instance, here are
some low-impact mutations,
variants where we've
been taking sun,
and they have a lot of mutation
or we have some things
that are most severe.
Typically the most severe things
have lower frequencies.
In the sample,
they were quite rare.
Okay.
[ Speaks indistinctly ]
So it gives us a global overview
of what we've done
and we can begin
to take anything into space.
And so these are
some general statistics.
You can see various things here.
So, for instance, one data set
at a high level of duplication.
So perhaps it was sequenced
very deep.
We can also see that
in that percent,
it's going to be low.
So this might indicate that
maybe there is some human needs
that are within this mixture.
There's few proper pairs,
which again,
highlight what have been
artificially moved.
And we can see...
where...
We can see the impact
that it had.
[ Speaks indistinctly ]
So let's keep in mind
this is a list.
Typically, you do
some addition of it.
Okay, you can see
how many reads we have,
so this is the largest data set.
This is the smallest data set.
Okay.
If there are any additional
questions...
If not, then I think we can go
back to the slides.
Clements: Thank you, Marius.
There were a lot of questions
while you were talking.
So most of them have been
answered in the Q&A.
We currently have one
open question from Pablo.
"In the trimming step,
does Galaxy identify
automatically all sorts
of adapter sequences
that may be present
or should we specify them?"
If you know them,
it's always better to specify
them explicitly.
If you don't know them,
it does recognize the most
common sequence and adapters,
but if their prevalence
is relatively low,
it might not find them.
So that's...
I just want to add here
that Galaxy
doesn't identify anything.
What it identifies
is the tools that it has.
So in this particular case,
we're using fastp,
which recognizes
automatically some types
of adapters and trims them.
There is also trimmomatic,
which is in the Galaxy,
which we didn't use
in this example.
There is Trim Galore!
In particular, in case
of SARS-CoV-2,
if you're using ampliconic data,
so this data sets
have specific primers
that they're used for amplifying
in reaching,
particularly SARS-CoV-2
sequences.
And so you have to know them
and there are tools for dealing
with them specifically.
That is an IVAR tool set
for cleaving of amplicon primers
off of these reads.
It's also in Galaxy.
We're not showing it
as part of this example,
but it's there.
But in order to use it,
you need to know adapter
sequences that you're using.
Thanks, Anton.
Another question
from Tusharica.
"Is it possible to form plots
in Galaxy which show us
which are the common genes
present in each sample?"
Anybody want to take that?
In relation to SARS-CoV-2
or in general?
I'm not sure.
I doubt any of us understands
exactly what do you mean.
So in general.
-In general.
Okay, so, I mean,
this is a bit difficult
to answer that
from multiple perspectives.
So if you want to see,
for instance,
which genes have a mutation,
we could generate
a tabular file,
and then there are tools
in Galaxy
to plot tabular data.
There are visualizations
we can display.
One axis versus the other.
These are relatively
simple tools.
If you do know how to use
ART Studio or Jupiter,
you can load up the data
that are generated
and then use ART Studio
or Jupiter within Galaxy
to look at that question.
And we have also --
we have a GT plot,
which also lets you display
different columns,
different colors.
So we don't have
necessarily something
specifically for genes,
but as soon as we put that
into a table,
you can generate plots.
Thank you, Marius.
So we have
one more outstanding question,
but in the interest of time,
I'm gonna move on.
So, Sharika,
I'm gonna show some resources
on the last slide
that you can follow up with
or if any of the panelists
want to answer that via text,
feel free, okay?
So thank you, Marius.
That was wonderful.
Let's go back and I'll see
if I can share my screen.
Share.
Wow, I feel like
I'm in the 20th century,
21st century, sorry.
Okay.
Okay, so these are the resources
I was referring to.
We have a bunch from SRA
and a bunch from Galaxy.
Again, these slides
are available online.
And we'll also post links
to these slides, probably --
Well, I don't know about SRA,
but we certainly
will from Galaxy.
So if you have questions
about SRA,
that's the e-mail at SRA.
Lots and lots of resources
at SRA and NCBI, in general.
Really a ton of stuff.
There are some links to this
in the tutorial itself.
There also is guidance
about how to submit data,
which is a very common question.
For Galaxy,
there's a number of resources.
Galaxyproject.org
is the community hub.
It's a website
about all things Galaxy.
And in theory,
it links out to all parts
of the Galaxy ecosystem.
A couple of places
to ask questions, get help,
help.galaxyproject.org.
It is a discourse-based online
forum, Q&A forum.
It's quite popular,
quite friendly.
The community is also
If you prefer a chat interface,
we use Gitter for that.
And that's what the Gitter link
takes you to.
You can ask questions there.
That works well for a lot
of give-and-take and questions
that you can state
in a short way.
If it takes so long time
to describe your question,
then help might be more useful.
I mentioned earlier
there are over 100
Galaxy instances
that are publicly accessible.
Here are three of them,
which are the big ones.
Usegalaxy.org
run by the U.S. team.
Usegalaxy.eu run
by the European team
and usegalaxy.org.au
run by the Australian team.
There are also more of these
in the works.
There's a use Galaxy Belgium,
for instance, that's out there.
France, Spain,
Southeast Asia and Taiwan
are all in various steps
of coming along.
The last thing
I want to highlight
is our annual conference,
which is at that URL.
We are co-locating
with BOSC this year,
the Bioinformatics
Open Source Conference.
It's really --
Well, it's online obviously.
It's at the end of July.
And it's really,
really affordable.
And no matter where you are
in the world, you can attend
because we are mirroring
our content in both hemispheres.
So we're hosting out of Toronto,
and we're hosting out
of eastern Australia as well.
So 12 hours apart,
everything twice each day.
Okay.
So the last slide.
Thank you.
We'd really like to thank
our NCBI collaborators,
Yuriy, who's on the call,
as is Lydia and Ravinder.
I don't know if Kurt
and Sergiy --
I'm sorry if I'm not pronouncing
that correctly --
are on the call or not.
But they were both instrumental
in getting this to work.
We'd like to thank NIAID, NHGRI,
and NSF
because they provide us
with funding.
And last but certainly
not least, the Galaxy community.
And again, without them,
we would not be who we are.
Anton: And Dave,
if I might just finish.
So this -- Again,
we're very grateful to SRA
for initiating this.
And SRA provides...
I lost my Zoom interface here.
Yes.
So SRA provides open data.
And what we're adding here,
we're adding open tools
and open infrastructure
to analyze this data.
Because if you, if any of you
on this webinar,
will decide to download
10,000 SRA data sets,
you will be able to do that.
And you will be able to map them
and to analyze them.
And so this will -- this
will be happening somewhere.
And this is one of the reasons
why we have NSF there,
because NSF funds national
supercomputing infrastructure
and Galaxy runs out of
Texas Advanced Computing Center,
which allows any one of you
to analyze very large data.
So I want to thank them.
And again, I want to thank SRA
for initiating this.
This is -- it's early stages.
We're probably going
to have some problems.
And so for you users,
it's important to let us know
what these problems are
so we can fix them.
Thank you.
Thank you, Anton.
And thank you all last,
certainly not least again,
for sticking with us
for the whole 75 minutes
of this call.
And we look forward
to hearing from you
on those contacts
and support channels.
Okay. And that's it.
I'm gonna stop the recording.